ma petite-fille
a été perdue pour nous
je voudrais qu'elle me revienne après le goût
et vous monsieur on
me dit
de l'homme pour faire le travail
chaque bras est équipé d'un engin explosif
votre pantalon est également équipé
d'explosifs
vraiment
juste au-delà du point où  nous sommes maintenant debout
se trouve une autoroute où le mal règne
qu'est-ce que c'est au bout de cinq jours si
tu n'es pas revenu avec bernice eh
bien je pense que tu as l'idée fils bon
Dieu
c'est le pays fantôme
une terre sans échappatoire
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui tiennent  son capitaine
ça fait deux jours
et elle a toujours disparu
comment puis-je sortir d'ici
tu dois te rendre au destin
bébé
radioactif
personne n'échappe au fantôme laissé
je ne suis pas un prisonnier
toi